oh thank an exclusive hey when I this
one only mrs. thanksgiving DJ drama you
know my man bootleg Kevin's in this
Vegas stand up top now 75 let's go and
live in studio we got the homie DJ drama
yo we in this man booth a kid was
happening hey bro welcome to the city
man welcome to Vegas eyes I see you in
town chillin with Paul water night for
his birthday yeah you know me and paul
wall got it crackin over the gallery so
we going in you know me so i had to stop
to come check you for a minute
appreciate it now you got the new record
we in this yeah you got like everybody
that is from Atlanta that really matters
all on one song and well not everybody
but the legends some some good ones yeah
that really matter Jeezy huh they never
been on a record together not inevitably
of them haven't been on a record
together surprisingly which is kind of
crazy he's kind of crazy um and then
shot the future of course of course then
it the young blood out of Atlanta um I
heard you were sitting on the record for
a while yeah I heard jeez each other in
an interview um it's kind of the story
you know I came up with the record the
concept of the record went um I was
still working on third power you know I
guess around the time of of oh my oh my
remix so you know I took at the future
you know I told him the idea um of
course you know Cain gave me an
incredible beat ya and my goal actually
was to put the record out around when I
was doing third power but I also you
know tip was still locked up and I
wanted to hold it you know I mean I
definitely wanted tip involved on the
record so I held it a little bit and I
really you know I was the labor was
pushing me to get the album you know in
the store so respectfully you know I
mean up at their power out it did what
it did and you know I mean we had that
we in this which it kind of worked out
in a way you know because here we are
back with a whole new momentum and I
Connor was able to work my new project
quality street music around having that
record right you know I'm saying with
with it with without being up being able
to put it on third power so you know
shelter to everybody involved man it's
definitely a statement you know it feels
good to see all those gosselin record
together and it's feeling strong out
there Atlanta is like there's a new
resurgence man commune definitely change
got future crazy on Travis Porter cash
out
I scroll dash you know a lot of kids
shot my man DJ spinz DJ screaming a lot
of people in the city doing big things I
was definitely man so I'm we're just
trying to talking you the first artists
I've ever interviewed it i skirted
anything that's funny cuz I had to pull
some strings man because they call me
bootleg care cuz I used to slang
mixtapes at the swap meet I've never
knew that 5 4 20 I've never knew that I
used to burn like that the latest DJ
drama I can't ban the snowman saw that
you're upset with these make you most
money with uh DJ drama okay perfect it
was always drama and back then southern
smoke yep was a small those were the
lakes um and then all the game stuff you
know but yeah yeah so you made me a lot
of money you help feed my newborn man
when I was like 17 so I appreciate it
hence the name is the thanksgiving we
feed these streets yo man so much love
though but yeah I was like I was I was I
think I was an intern and I was like no
y'all you feeling me like DJ drama thats
that's like you know i'm a fan yeah let
me interview me know i remember you had
to uh mixtapes will never die shirt yeah
and it makes you in this shirt so yeah
from its unit it's crazy for you to tell
that because you know you know from one
DJ to another you always like to see uh
you know people do anything so you know
I mean I definitely give you kudos and
your props on on everything you've been
doing and you know I mean your videos we
just tell my content like who can say
they they had Justin Bieber you know rap
on a shot Jimmy you know man it's a
threats cuz it an able man much love
though um let's talk about the new
project you would say was called quality
stream music quality music that you
still with same label situation yeah I'm
over 81 you know any1 affiliates you
know I mean is still ground house was
the family so we still rockin so um I
definitely got some some good things and
it was interesting me trying to put this
I'm together every time you want to kind
of come with an angle so you know I'm
really into brands and quality street
music is it something I came up with a
while ago on a jeezy mixtape on when we
was doing tribe of dying I still you
know part of the gangsta grillz family
and what it means and you know but being
able to come up with certain records and
you know still really embraced a lot of
you know the new movement and new guys
doing things so you know I got some
interesting things it still seems like
you are like the you know you are
one guy to go to to drop that mixtape
you know what latest one is the Don trip
that I've been having bangs were icic I
think I've seen you tweet about that
shuttered I'm sure Barry by Memphis um
I'm actually about to drop the YG tape
to me and thank me it will and DJ
mustard so I'm a mom I'm excited about
that cuz you know i mean why he's
definitely uh he's been working and I've
been the Westco he's crazy he's got he
got bangers makes got a lot of bangla
show so he's deserving of that um but
you know it feels good because even with
a lot of the new cats too because i know
in today's world to you know a lot of a
lot of artists are going and doing no DJ
projection yeah i mean so effing Utley
to still be able to you know people are
still recognize that my brand is strong
and important and and enjoy what I do
you know I mean it feels good what is up
to you what I like cuz of course since
the days where you were you know coming
up as the man you know I mean when you
first started coming off the gangster
grill and mixtapes where people still
bought them online still you know what
good old a room downloading a more a lot
harder you had to kind of be like a real
internet every person to get them joined
exactly and what what do you think the
benefit is still having you know guys
like yourself host mixtapes of course
the brand is very important but other
than the brand uh I mean still I still a
believer that you know when we when it
comes to mix tape you know a mixtape I
mean it's still supposed to if its a mix
tape supposed to have a DJ yeah you know
I mean so call it a mixtape by the way
you know I mean truth be told and you
know I'm not a big fan of the no DJ
tapes after you know you've done a tape
with a DJ and so you know meaning so for
myself to really still be waving the
flag you know it's important and and I'm
totally for you know a lot of whoever if
you want to put a project out without a
DJ you know and I get it you know i mean
if you call it a mix tape but you know
i'm a hard case they say on the radio
the other day like don't be scared
that's your album you know I'm saying
like you all ciao it's your album if
you're not using the DJ that's your
album but you know salute to all the
guys that really still have moved the
culture forward even with their projects
you know Jake Draco
and so many others you know whether you
use a DJ I now but you know I'm a DJ I
grew up listening to the to the greats
you know so I'm always gonna represent
radio DJ all I get a mix ni damn can't
play this though cuz cuz there's DJ
drops all over you know a no DJ version
when it comes out it helps like guys
like myself here's here's the thing
here's where I'm where I'm at with with
that and with artists because I totally
get that and because these are radio DJs
exactly and because these projects are
that important to you know artists his
career right now i totally get having to
have records without DJ's on it but
there's a thing it's a way to go about
it you don't have to put a hole no DJ
tape out the thing to do is you take
important records off the tape you get
them to the DJ's you said you know I
mean I mean if you're on your job you
know you have your people get them to
the radio DJs you got to clean them up
anyway so you clean them up you take the
drops off and you get those records out
just as you would do an album and send
records out don't put a no DJ version
out if you're going to use a DJ user DJ
using but don't come back and disrespect
my brand and just put a no DJ tape out
you know if the point of putting it out
in the first place I've had these
conversations with artist that I've done
tapes with and you know and just voice
my opinion on it and you know me and I
just I just think that you know if
you're gonna if you're gonna call it a
mixtape you're going to use a DJ go in
you know if you're not you're not it's
all good but you know I mean we're here
for a reason and you know and and you
wouldn't come to us if our value in our
work wasn't something let me ask you
this man you've had so many mixtapes
like I'm sure hundreds man um what is
like two or three that that are you you
know personal favorites you know I got a
lot I mean you notice there's ones that
are sentimentally but as far as like you
know quality wise music wise are you
just like yo this this right here is you
know it's tough man it I mean I mean
clearly I always look at my three
classes is amazing man I think about
some of them sometimes I guess I'm still
astonished I mean my on three-peat you
know is definitely down with the king
tribo da and dedication to like I
wouldn't be here if it wasn't for those
three tapes um but you know I mean I
love the Pharrell tape a lot of little
brother I'll take the ice cream and pray
um and so many matter i like i love the
fab series um yeah you know I even I
love all the dedications but even
dedication 3 is amazing to me because
when I look back and I and I and I see
what Wayne was trying to do with young
money on that project and really put
them forward with nicki and drake and
taking everybody like to see them now
it's crazy um that the dead prez tape
little brother tables yeah little
brother take was amazing you know
anytime I can kind of do one outside the
box oh of course you know Chris Brown in
my zone I think that was a monumental
moment for music when we did that tape
as well as the art Kelly tape you know I
mean because I remember Tom you know
even in my career early when people will
come to me about R&B gangsta grillz and
mixtapes and it kind of didn't really
you know there was a time when people
make ir I never had that angle a little
bit with tray back in the day definitely
you know it and I remember you know it's
funny because me atrae we know each
other for years you know I was on his
second album and I remember coming to VA
early on in his career and he came to he
came to checking into hotel and he
brought through like you know about
12-15 freestyles you know he was ready
then you know ready on deck to go so you
know he's definitely somebody that
embraced her early and was doing this
thing so you know it's amazing to see
where when mixtapes have gone and how
you know me even from the raid situation
that happened to me too to wear them you
know everybody in every form is using a
full platform you know and I think it's
a great thing it's a great story you
know I've always told how important they
are to the culture and you know the
music so to see where the mixtape game
is or where mixtapes are across the
board it had become such mainstream
things is no it's fantastic indeed man
um what other tapes can you tell us
about anything you're working on right
now pretty focused on this this album
definitely got tapes in a pipeline but
the album is coming along crazy we got
on that well man we got some things we
definitely got some things I don't want
I don't want to go and shout out to uh
to drama who actually got Outkast to do
a joint for me I saw my dad does I
remember
yo there was always talk about outcast
gangsta grillz and it never happened
that's out of been crazy that's how the
song actually happen because you know we
talked about the tape we were going to
do it and dream big call me and it was
like you know we can't give you the tape
because you know the schedule is just
crazy but we'll do a song for your album
so and it's just amazing you know and
it's kind of funny because with all due
respect I feel like Atlantic kind of
dropped the ball on that because you
know Andre wanted to do the video but
you know there's a couple of numbers
involved that was necessary to happen
and they weren't ready to do it but I
mean that song was amazing and great
record I'm everywhere I dance together I
show back in Phoenix man that was mine
not only that was crazy so you know it's
it's um that's another man it's just
crazy that I got outcast on the record i
got got some of those 3,000 bars that
still to this day people like fee for
definitely hate the album is dropping
you have any ballpark yet mmm i'm
thinking maybe uh maybe like early july
and we don't we gonna see where it is
about to shoot the video for we in this
so look out for that you know see how
that goes maybe remix it or something
and uh got a couple other records on
deck that I'm definitely gonna be hot
summer night artistry music coming this
summer keep a lookout dramas do album
come you to do single you get it on
itunes yet yes on there so itunes right
now make sure you go get that the
website drama like to deejay com got the
blog ain't proper now yeah we working it
out you know I mean definitely got them
bootleg keV interviews on there much
love man love get you coming through
brother yeah I know